in washington schaut man mit
hochspannung auf die vereidigung von joe
biden zum 46
us-präsidenten in der nächsten woche
gespannt weil wieder gewaltsame
ausschreitungen befürchtet werden und
gespannt auf das was bis dahin mit
donald trump geschieht
sein vize präsident will den bisher
nicht für amtsunfähig erklären lassen
die meisten republikaner halten auch
nach der stürmung des kapitols zu ihm
die demokraten setzen jetzt auf ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren der kann für
ruhe sorgen einer so aufgebrachten lage
letzte stunden im weißen haus wie geht
es weiter mit trump unser thema in der
phoenix runde
dieses amtsenthebungsverfahren das jetzt
angestrengt wird ist die fortsetzung der
größten hexenjagd überhaupt das ist
absolut lächerlich
dieses verfahren sorgt für wut und zorn
es ist eine ganz furchtbare sache idee
während machen er die gemüter sind noch
nicht wo holt herzlich willkommen aus
berlin so phoenix runde und ich darf
ihnen meine gäste vorstellen gilt haft
ist bei uns deutsch amerikanische
entertainerin seit 2017 da hat sie die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft angenommen
unter anderem auch aus protest gegen
donald trump und sie hat jetzt joe biden
gewählt hat sie uns verraten in einer
der letzten sendungen und markus kaim
ist bei uns politikwissenschaftler bei
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
und er war bis juli bis diesen sommer
oder bis letzten sommer 2020 waren sie
stipendiat des german marshall funds in
washington herzlich willkommen und
zugeschaltet aus frankfurt ist uns ralf
freund der ist unternehmensberater
vertreter im publikum roger me mitglied
der republikanischen partei also und
aber auch der cdu herzlich willkommen
herr freund und aus washington ist uns
zugeschaltet jan-philipp burg ads usa
korrespondent für die ard herr burkhardt
sie bereiten sich natürlich auch schon
vor auf diese nächste woche was merkt
man jetzt im moment nach diesem sturm
auf das kapitol in der letzten woche wie
ist die situation jetzt gerade in
washington
ja man merkt dass die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen schon jetzt
erheblich verschärft werden rund um das
kapitol ist ein neuer sicherheitszaun
errichtet worden
es werden 15 1000 nationalgardisten
mobilisiert haben wir vorhin erfahren
bemerkenswert daran ist dass ein
abgeordneter der demokratischen partei
gefordert hat diese nationalgardisten zu
durchleuchten um sicherzustellen dass
niemand von ihnen mit inländischen
terroristen sympathisiert und
tatsächlich hat die us-armee auch
prüfungen angekündigt dann ist
besprochen worden dass die
sicherheitsstufe schon jetzt an diesem
mittwoch noch einmal erhöht wird
eigentlich war das erst für samstag
geplant also washington wird jetzt immer
mehr
so zwang zur festung ausgebaut und man
spürt eben dass die sicherheitsdienste
alles tun wollen um bilder wie wir sie
in der vergangenen woche gesehen haben
auf jeden fall zu vermeiden und wie
bereitet man sich weiter politisch
darauf vor ist es möglich ist soll heute
abend gibt es noch die sitzung des
repräsentantenhauses dass donald trump
doch noch gehen muss vor der vereidigung
seines nachfolgers
ich persönlich halte das für sehr
unwahrscheinlich die demokraten streben
dennoch ein neues
amtsenthebungsverfahren dann heute abend
wird im repräsentantenhaus eine
resolution wohl zur abstimmung gebracht
da möchte man den druck auf
vizepräsident pence und das kabinett
erhöhen den präsidenten für amtsunfähig
zu erklären
es ist allerdings zweifelhaft dass es
dazu kommt man hat pence ein ultimatum
gestellt er hat 24 stunden zeit darauf
zu reagieren sollte fans und das
kabinett das nicht mehrheitlich
bescheiden dann will man morgen im
repräsentantenhaus die eigentliche
amtsenthebung einleiten oder das
verfahren morgen ein laden mit einer
weiteren abstimmung aber das verfahren
würde ja dann noch einige wochen dauern
genau deswegen ist es auch
unwahrscheinlich denn zum einen bräuchte
man eine zweidrittelmehrheit im senat um
den präsidenten tatsächlich des amtes zu
entheben und auch wenn vereinzelt
republikaner jetzt rampe zum rücktritt
aufgerufen haben es ist aber doch sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass am ende 17
republikanische senatoren zu den
demokraten überlaufen würden also das
ist unwahrscheinlich und dann sie haben
es gesagt der senat tritt ohnehin erst
am 19 januar wieder zusammen
der demokratische minderheitsführerin
schumer hat zwar heute die senatoren
aufgefordert früher sich wieder in
washington zu treffen aber es ist
zweifelhaft dass es dazu kommt also
deswegen ist es so gut wie
ausgeschlossen dass trump tatsächlich
noch vor dem offiziellen ende seiner
amtszeit am 20 januar des amtes enthoben
wird steht allerdings auch noch die
möglichkeit im raum
das in pietschmann verfahren nach seinem
ausscheiden aus dem weißen haus weiter
zu betreiben okay da reden wir nochmal
drüber
was dann mit jump danach vielleicht wird
herr freund sie sind ich habe es gesagt
mit der republikanischen partei wenn sie
jetzt mit stimmen könnten oder wenn sie
in der position des vize präsidenten
wären würden sie jetzt donald trump
raten den hut zu nehmen also der
vizepräsident marc penz ist gut beraten
das nicht zu tun
einfach die zeit ist viel zu kurz bis
dorthin dann könnte der präsident wendet
mike pence ist tatsächlich einleiten
würde könnte der präsident wieder
sprechen dann müsste es wieder zur
abstimmung kommen also ganz so leicht
geht das nicht pence bräuchte auch die
mehrheit des kabinetts ist fraglich aber
die überhaupt bekommen würde
ich glaube man sollte jetzt die letzten
tage verstreichen lassen strategisch
halte es auch für falsch weil man
vielleicht das macht das tram gerade
möchte dass wir in diese märtyrer
position kommt er dann wieder zu sagen
kann
zu seinen anhängern seht her das
establishment in washington ist ohnehin
korrupt ist es ohnehin will mich im
rausdrängen ihr habt mich gewählt und
die wollen mich wieder wegschicken das
gibt ihm nur nährboden für
möglicherweise in jetzt während der
amtszeit von joe biden weiterhin zu
agitieren
also ich würde sagen der präsident der
wenig präsidiale war auf den letzten
metern jetzt sollte es friedlich
verlassen und man sollte ihn nicht an er
war wenig präsidial sagen sie halten sie
ihnen denn auch für amtsunfähig nein
keineswegs
er weiß genau was er tut und das ist
glaube ich der schaden für die
demokratie uns vielleicht auch schon mal
vorweg zu nehmen sehe ich jetzt nicht im
sturm aufs kapital das wird als tragödie
in uns jahrzehntelang wahrscheinlich
weiter verfolgen dass es tote gab
aber politisch glaube ich kann das
amerikanische demokratie eine stabile
demokratie aushalten was viel
gravierender ist
präsident jean sprach von wahlbetrug
natürlich gab es wahl unregelmäßigkeiten
aber das waren nicht ergebnis eines
betruges etwa sondern das waren eben
auch ein menschliches versagen dabei bei
einigen wahlautomaten bei einigen
auszählung aber dass der wähler
vielleicht im gedächtnis hat dass seine
stimme nicht zählt weil sie manipuliert
worden ist dass ich die gleiche gewicht
hat wie beispielsweise bei einer wahl in
russland oder gar weißrussland ich
glaube das ist der größere schaden für
die demokratie
so weit sollte man hat sich das im
vorfeld schon angedeutet herr burkhardt
hat auch schon gesagt dass das im
vorfeld auch schon einige sich bewegt
hat ich glaube das war der eigentliche
schaden der demokratie nicht so sehr der
sturm jetzt auf das kapital ok vortag
sie sehen sie es als amerikanerin auch
jetzt mit deutscher staatsangehörigkeit
was haben sie empfunden dieser sturm auf
das kapitol was war das für sie war das
ein schaden für die demokratie
es war ein schaden für mein herz es war
die show ein schaden für dich herz jeder
amerikaner finde ich finde es natürlich
ein schaden für die demokratie
das war so schockierend denn das war
terroristen
endlich sind einfach gegangen ein
gestürmt andy intent war nicht nur
friedvolle protest zu machen das ist
ganz klar
die waren bewaffnet die waren es war ein
mord das war ein coup das war ein putsch
und das war für mich schockierend ich
habe nie so was ich bin 60 jahre alt
gibt nichts was in meinem leben gesehen
nine eleven kommt nach aber das war wir
waren nicht alle da der war nicht leute
sagen ja mach es auch der präsident hat
nicht gesagt ja bringen diese struktur
mal unten
das ist das war mir so schockierend und
so ich bin jetzt wirklich seit seit
einer woche meinte es tut mir einfach
körperlich weh diese bürger dass wir
immerhin immer wieder sehen ich muss
irgendwann jeden tag sagen okay stop
guckt nicht mehr und rutschen oder
irgendwelche andere serie würden sie
denn sagen das tram das ist die schuld
von donald trump oder welche schule ihre
haltung dass andere feiert das ist ganz
klar viele leute freunde von mir gemerkt
haben gesagt ja wir haben auch die
bilder gesehen von eweek stark von der
querdenker demo wenn ich hab gesagt ja
aber frau merkel war nicht da hinten
haben gesagt ja mag das anders
und die sind nicht drin gekommen und ich
finde diese werden
er sagt dass er hat das nicht angefeuert
seine worte hat keine bedeutung das war
alles sehr harmlos es waren die teams
sind auch wenn er was er gesagt
vielleicht nicht genau
ich habe so habe ich das geschrieben
inside me to head auf irgendwelchen muss
das gucken heute zum aufruhr anregen er
hat das gemacht und auch sorry das ist
seine clique das ist seiner das ist
einer mafia das ist seine leute und die
frage welche konsequenzen daraus zieht
die demokraten sagen jetzt muss er muss
das amt entheben
dort werden ndr ist halt eben nicht mehr
ist nicht mehr das amt des fähigkeit ist
das eine sinnvolle taktik der demokrat
ein sinnvolles handeln der demokraten
also ich formuliere es mal so sollte ich
glaube beiden gerade in diesen tagen
beraten dass man so sich aber vorstellen
keinen moment
ich würde ihn dringend davon abraten und
ich finde es auch kein zufall dass der
angehende präsident sich in den letzten
tagen dieser feier sehr zurückgehalten
hat es gibt vielfältige äußerung von
vielen gehören präsenten der
demokratischen partei globalen hat sie
sehr zurückgehalten und ich glaube sieht
die sachlage sehr klar
donald trump wird in der einen oder
anderen form mindestens für vier jahre
in diesem amt das die bühne politische
bühne verlassen wir müssen also nicht
was er machen würde
wir wissen nicht welche rolle er
weiterhin für die amerikanische portal
spielen wird aber als präsent für die
bühne verlassen wenn nicht die bühne
verlassen wird sind die 74 millionen
amerikanischen weber die ihn gewählt
haben und das ist glaube ich der
startpunkt nicht nur für republikanische
strategen also all diejenigen die jetzt
überlegen wie sie 20 24 republikanischer
präsidentschaftskandidat werden die
überlegen genau so nehmen die 74
millionen als stab- und ihrer
überlegungen aber genauso wird der
angehende präsident überlegen müssen
wenn ihr das denn ernst meint mit
brücken bauen versöhnen dass er ihn
irgendwie eine art programmatisches
angebot machen muss und vor dem
hintergrund ist es natürlich ein fatales
signal auch wenn ich die motive im
einzelnen verstehe was in den augen der
74 millionen oder von vielen teilen als
eine art siegerjustiz wirken muss nicht
dass ich das so sehe aber es ist leicht
so war das thema angesprochen da würde
ich einfach so zustimmen
und angesichts dieses überwinden konsens
ist sagen wie weit wollen wir die
polarisierung oder die spaltung ist dann
ist er noch weiter treiben wäre ich auch
bei ralf freund zu sagen lasst uns die
letzten tage geordnet über die bühne
gehen und dann wird das land in einen
neuen transformation oder traditions-
modus schalten
aber das mitmacht ist natürlich fraglich
ich wünschte er würde einfach kaufen
gehen ja vielleicht kann einfach urlaub
machen auf dem golfplatz herr burkhard
wie sehen die demokraten das also dieses
argument dass donald trump durch so
einen im bieterverfahren ja auch in
einem erd ihre position kommen kann und
dass dann noch mehr zu einer eskalation
kommen kann wie wird man das diskutiert
bei den demokraten
ja ich glaube bei den demokraten steht
die motivation im vordergrund ein
zeichen zu setzen dem symbol an amerika
und auch an den rest der welt zu senden
dass der präsident dieses mal zu weit
gegangen ist dass er sich nicht alles
erlauben kann dass sein handeln
konsequenzen hat wenn es auch nur
symbolische sind ich glaube eine zweite
motivation ist so eine art drohkulisse
aufzubauen auch für diese letzten tage
im amt und den präsidenten dazu zu
bringen ja weitere entgleisungen zu
vermeiden weil dann vielleicht doch
einige republikaner die seiten wechseln
könnten
also das sind zu dir die hauptmotive die
da gerade bei den demokraten eine rolle
spielen ich bin aber auch bei markus
kaim dass ich das strategisch er für
nachteilig halte denn sollte das
amtsenthebungsverfahren auch über das
ausscheiden präsident trump aus dem
weißen haus hinaus weiter betrieben
werden
dann wäre der senat auch erstmal
blockiert sozusagen da würde sehr viel
zeit absorbiert für dieses verfahren die
eigentlich dringend nötig wäre für den
neuen präsidenten joe biden und seine
agenda voranzutreiben
man weiß ja nicht wie lange er diese
hauchdünne mehrheit in beiden kammern
er hat und ich glaube da könnten sich
die demokraten sozusagen selbst jetzt
einen klotz ans bein hängen
herr freund was würden was wünschen sie
sich denn für ihre partei
trump jetzt nicht mehr präsident ist was
wäre denn das wichtigste damit ihre
partei in der es ja nun auch genug
diskussionen gibt und nicht alle mehr
dem präsidenten ebene folgen
damit diese partei wieder nach vorne
gehen kann vielleicht auch ohne job
oder geht das nur noch mit sein wird
ohne tramper vorne gehen
aber sie wird eine sie hat nicht diese
spaltung wie immer behauptet wird vor
allen dingen nicht politisch es gibt
natürliche strömungen die champion wie
ich sie nenne oder auch die spieler die
grand old party anhänger zu der ich mich
ja erzähle aus den zeiten der bush ära
aber sie sind politisch nah beieinander
finanzpolitisch wirtschaftspolitisch
auch außenpolitisch sehr nah beieinander
der ton und auch in die die
apodiktischen worte die da ist man auch
sein da ist man auseinander recht auch
politisch ist der bogen nicht soweit und
man darf auch nicht vergessen dass jetzt
viele abgeordnete im kongress die jetzt
auch ein geworden zu gewonnen haben dass
die auf dem ticket gefahren sind und das
auch viele in den innerparteilichen in
den m vorwahl prozessen haben auf die
campina den vorzug bekommen von der
parteibasis gegenüber den anderen
kandidaten
das heißt diese leute sind jetzt im neu
gewählten kongress und wie schnell die
sich emanzipieren können von dem
präsidenten auf denen der unterstützt
worden ist von 84 millionen wähler in
wertheim das richtig sagte das ist
fraglich das zweite ist auch was hier zu
kurz kommt ist das demokratische partei
auch bei den gouverneurswahlen die
es setze alle halten konnten dass sie
ihre mandate auf bundesstaats ebene
ausgeweitet haben über 120 mandaten über
alle bundesstaaten weg hinzugewonnen
haben dass man in einigen staaten gibt
es auch mittlerweile das steakhouse also
auch die parlamente mehrheitsfähig
geschafft hat das heißt ist wie viele
dinge in der zweiten reihe die auch
passiert sind man kann es über ganz
überein ausdrücken also holzschnittartig
ausdrücken
man hat den präsidenten hauchdünn
abgewählt aber die amerikanischen partei
hat hauchdünnen zugelegt also es ist
kein prozess der spaltung den ich im
augenblick sehe in ihrer partei aber
eine spaltung des landes vortags wo
sehen sie denn sie anschauen die donald
trump gewählt haben wie kriegt man das
wieder zusammen wie kommt man überhaupt
noch in einen dialog oder geht das gar
nicht mehr nach diesem sturm auf das
kapitol
das ist der große frage dass er frage
der stunde natürlich bleibe optimistisch
ich glaube aber wir sprechen nicht
natürlich über die ganze elefanten mit
meanwhile 400.000 leute sind an cockpit
gestorben
das ist ein land das das nicht nur das
traumatisiert ist nicht nur vernetzte
woche und es ist harte harte zeiten frau
merkel ich glaube dass ich stimmt sie
total zu es gibt tatsachen die muskeln
einfach jetzt gemacht werden denn das
ist egal
das ist finanziell für familien bildung
etc schulen alle die dinge dass wir hier
haben haben die vielmehr war das ist ein
großes land und die haben das 1 4
heftiger mit mit corona zu tun und ich
glaube nur nach der 20 nächste woche
immer wieder mit trump beschäftigt zu
werden wollte sind erschöpft sollte sind
fertig mit den nerven oder ob sie das in
oder sind sie nicht gerade jetzt
besonders angestachelt uns fühlen sich
ermutigt so nach dem motto jetzt geht's
erst richtig los mit heim und wo bisher
wir sprechen über die die leute die welt
schon gewählt haben aber leute haben
und ich glaube es gibt genug frauen in
diesem land ich glaube irgendwie wir
kommen zusammen
sie waren in washington das erlebt also
kriegt man da noch ein dialog hin ist es
jetzt so wenn das gefühlvoll jetzt jetzt
holen wir uns eben das capitol unser
haus zurück das wurde da gerufen
und das endet ja nicht ist ja nicht
geändert jetzt mit der letzten woche
also ich will mich nicht im kalender
sprüche flüchten oder zahl zu versöhnen
oder zu hause nur gehören immer zwei
also natürlich kann der amerikanische
präsident der angehende jetzt in seiner
antrittsrede das hohelied der versöhnung
singen des brückenbauers was nach dem
wahlkampf jetzt angebot angemessen sei
habe die entscheidende frage ist doch
die die wir gerade auch schon angedeutet
haben wie wir in die republikaner darauf
reagieren und welchen kurs wären sie
einschlagen
ansonsten keine präsident mit seinen
knappen mehrheiten im senat mit einer
verminderten mehrheit im
repräsentantenhaus strampeln mir möchte
er wird der wird da nicht weit kommen
und die kleine frau wird wirklich sein
die berater angewöhnt wir haben wird es
eine art von kubismus ohne trump geben
und da gibt es ja indizien für oder
protagonisten niemand nennen kann
die in den letzten tagen oder wochen
hervorgetreten sind ein ted price of
texas an klorolle aus missouri ein tom
courtenay soll das sind figuren wo man
sich vorstellen könnte die dass die
diesen pfad genau mit blick auf 20 24
weiter einschlagen werden oder dass wir
der andere fahrt eine renaissance der
republikanischen partei entlang eines
moderateren kurs und da gibt es auch
namen die man könnte das wären so
gouverneure die auch in deren kontext
kubi krise eine gute figur gemacht haben
larry huras während mike die war ein
gouverneur von ohio
das wären so protagonisten auf die man
gucken kann lara hogan hat schon gesagt
20 24 würde seinen hut in den ring
werfen
aber ich traue mich nicht heute abend
sozusagen was welche diese wege die
republikanische partei einschlagen
aber ich glaube davon wird abhängen wie
war das mit der auszuüben und gehen kann
und das war ihre frage haben sie es
empfunden ist es das gefühl da fängt
jetzt so richtig erst was an oder ist
das jetzt erst mal das ende damit wenn
jump dann eben nicht mehr im amt ist
ich bin deutlich weniger optimistisch
als gayle tufts jetzt nach vier jahren
die ich jetzt in diesem land lebe habe
ich das gefühl dass ich nicht nur die
parteien im kongress sondern wirklich
auch zwei gesellschaftliche blöcke
völlig unversöhnlich gegenüberstehen das
hat mit sicherheit auch mit dem
mediensystem hier zu tun dass es im
grunde keinen öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk gibt sondern nur kommerziell
betriebene sender die politisch
ausgerichtet sind und eben nach der
logik des entertainments funktionieren
das heißt kommentar statt nachrichten
und jeder bürger geht sozusagen noch in
seine eigene echo kammer die
republikaner
hören eben verstärkt das was bei fox
news gesagt wird die liberalen haben das
was bei cnn gesagt hat und das hat jetzt
seit jahrzehnten dazu geführt dass jedes
lager nur noch seiner eigenen wahrheiten
hat und manchmal habe ich das gefühl wir
leben hier in so einem post faktischen
zeitalter also man kann sich über die
einfachsten wahrheiten nicht mehr
verständigen wenn man hier im land
unterwegs ist die bürger streiten sich
über die einzigen einfachsten fragen
selbst wenn die sonne scheint
würde man jemanden finden der sachen
ihres regnet ja und so vereinfacht
darzustellen
und ich glaube auch dass trump selbst
nicht so leicht verschwinden wird es
gibt tatsächlich ja diese indizien dass
er eine eigene plattform im internet
gegründet oder gar einen eigenen
fernsehsender also seine stimme wird
nicht verstummen und wir haben jetzt
immer wieder gesagt 74 millionen
menschen haben ihn gewählt und verehren
ihn weiterhin glühend und das sind nicht
nur die die beim sturm aufs kapital
dabei waren sondern auch ganz normale
leute überall im land und ich glaube er
wird er weiter versuchen auch wenn er
nicht mehr im weissen haus setzt sondern
in lago in florida jeden tag öl ins
feuer zu gießen und übrigens habe ich
auch im heimatort von joe biden sogar
viele menschen getroffen
viele republikaner die gesagt haben joe
biden ist nicht mein präsident und wird
nie mein präsident sein also mit dieser
attitüde rennen glaube ich viele
hunderttausend organ millionen
amerikaner durchs land herr freund hätte
hat samt die möglichkeit seine anhänger
so zu beruhigen dass es eben nicht so zu
diesen gewalttätigen
auseinandersetzungen kommt oder ist da
was sozusagen was jetzt auf einmal los
gegangen ist und was man gar nicht mehr
einfangen kann man die frage hat
eigentlich die sätze zwei dinge voraus
dass eine das jump ja nicht der
initiator dieser bewegung ist ein jump
hat das resultat bei seiner ersten wahl
2016 einer jahrelang nicht zu sagen
jahrzehntelangen entwicklung in den usa
aber natürlich dann auch verstärkt durch
acht jahre obama wo er dann auch viel
frustrationspotenzial aufgebaut wurde
und da hat sich an die spitze der
bewegung selbst und hat dann zum schluss
die sache natürlich auch noch befeuert
also dieser sturm aus kapitol und das
ist ja für mich vollkommen
unverständlich hätte vermieden werden
können
denn anscheinend haben ja die
geschäftsleute von washington hat wird
wahrscheinlich besser wissen als ich
haben einige habe ich die bilder gesehen
haben sich verbarrikadiert also die
haben mit gewalt gerechnet während die
sicherheitsbehörden ja sogar personal
abgezogen haben
und das ist schon äußerst merkwürdig ist
keine verschwörung irgendetwas sondern
glaube ich eine ganz schlichtes versagen
der behörden und einfach eine
unterschätzung der gewalt gewesen dass
das eine kann jumper das ganze dann
befeuert er ist sozusagen der
brandbeschleuniger gewesen aber nicht
die ursache er wird auch weiterhin im
amt bleiben ich glaube er wird weiterhin
dort seine meinung kundtun
die frage ist in der tat eher crime hat
angedeutet inwieweit ist dort im pfad
gibt dass sich die leute dort
emanzipieren innerhalb der
republikanischen partei und wieder ein
mehr programmatischen weg gehen oder ob
man mehr die company geht das wird
interessant sein zu beobachten und wenn
ich noch ein bisschen was den
politischen gegner sagen dürfte es wird
vor allen dingen interessant sein zu
beobachten wie es bei der demokratischen
partei im gesetzgebungsverfahren losgeht
sie hatten die frage gestellt nach
brücken bauen sie hatten die frage
gestellt nach der vereinigung der lage
ist interessant sein ob es soweit
überhaupt gelingt diese anti trump
koalition der sehr erfolgreich geführt
hat bis zu seiner wahl
die haben ihr ziel erreicht diese
antiken koalition kommt aus dem
waisenhaus zu verdrängen
die frage wird sein können die sich
überhaupt auf gemeinsame
gesetzesvorgaben vorlagen einigen also
es wird interessant sein zu sehen
gelingt es ihr überhaupt seine leute
hinter sich zu bringen um dann überhaupt
in einem zweiten schritt auf die
republikaner zugehen weil vieles was sie
wie ihr demokraten geeint hat vortags
war ja auch der vor allen dingen der
wunsch donald trump aus dem weißen haus
zu bekommen das haben sie geschafft
sehen sie da auch probleme dass man dann
ist man ist das klar wohin sich die
demokraten der entwickeln natürlich das
ist ein partei wie jede andere partei
es gibt ein liberaler
mehr links mehr in der mitte märz aber
ich weiß wie ich war unterwegs hier
heute abend in mein auto aus schöneberg
nachmieter und ich bin über gefahren
über was vor der wahl war kurz vorm
brandenburger tor es gibt so auf den
boden wo dem berliner mauer stadt wurde
berliner mauer war man kann über das
fahren und ich habe gedacht wow
die welt dreht sich dinge kann ändern
dass wir haben nicht gedacht die können
verändern
und ich denke vielleicht vermeint bin
ich zugeben ich bin nicht in washington
und sie war wichtig aber vielleicht
können wir ein bisschen hoffnung haben
da haben diese partei dass die würden
zusammenkommen das ist nicht nur
enttäuscht
es gibt dinge dass die demokratische
partei möchte machen ein niedriglohn
verlor mehr und unterstützung für frauen
für people of colour irgendwie dieser
rassismus das in merka so präsent ist
dass wir irgendwie einer eine weg nicht
zu 1 kalenders stück zu klingen aber
eine heilung so zu anzufangen aber warum
nicht aber in der welt gibt es ja auch
oft andere bewegungen her kein deshalb
nochmals die auch die frage wie
gefährlich kann das denn oder was könnte
noch passieren in diesen letzten tagen
also noch ist trump im amt er hat den er
ist oberbefehlshaber über eine sehr
starke armee
da muss man sich da eigentlich sorgen
machen dass da irgendwas noch passieren
könnte
also ich mache mir keine sorgen ehrlich
gesagt ich sehe natürlich ich kann dir
jetzt horrorszenarien dystopische
szenarien entwickeln dass er am letzten
tage noch wie nero mit rom sie wie nero
angesteckt hat washington oder der welt
an sind aber das scheint mir doch ein
wenig weit hergeholt ich glaube werden
tatsächlich sehen dass die machtübergabe
vergleichsweise nach diesem wahlkampf
geordnet über die bühne gehen würde
die eckpunkte sind bekannt er wird nicht
er in seinen feierlichkeiten teilnehmen
sondern wahrscheinlich golf spielen oder
was was sie hier machen und ich glaube
er wird in planung übergegangen sein
über das was wir eben preis spekuliert
haben wie seine rolle politische
ökonomische rolle unternehmerische rolle
in den nächsten wochen und monaten sein
wird und er hat wahrscheinlich genug
option sieht das zu überlegen und dann
am 20 januar tritt bei andern beiden an
einmal das aber bleibt man im moment bei
trump denn eine möglichkeit ist ja jetzt
genommen wurden ein twitter-account ist
gesperrt worden das wurde eben auch
heftig diskutiert aber twitter hat er
hat das gesperrt die bundeskanzlerin
merkel hält die sperrung für
problematisch das sei ein eingriff in
den grund recht auf meinungsäusserung
sagt sie das müsste dann das müsste der
gesetzgeber wenn machen aber nicht an
unternehmen hervor was macht das das tor
nicht mehr twittern kann ja zuerst mal
ist das natürlich ein nachteil für ihn
das war ja schon ein mächtiges werkzeug
der politischen kommunikation er konnte
direkt ohne irgendeinen filter der
konventionellen medien mit 88,4
millionen followern kommunizieren das
war natürlich für ihn tatsächlich ein
sehr wichtiges instrument
gleichzeitig kommt dann natürlich auch
wieder diese märtyrer rolle ins spiel
die vorhin schon mal anklang
und trump hatte das heute auch bei zwei
gelegenheiten
wieder gesagt dass ja
internetunternehmen jetzt nur mit den
liberalen und mit den linksradikalen
paktieren würden und ihn mundtot machen
wollten
und insofern wird er das glaube ich
nutzen für seine art der verschwörungs
erzählung und es ihnen weiter motivieren
einen eigenen kanal zu entwerfen er hat
schon angekündigt dass er da in kürze
etwas präsentieren wolle
und deswegen rechne ich fest damit dass
kraft sich einen neuen kanal suchen wird
mit dem wir dann agieren kann
schon kurz nachdem er das weiße haus
verlassen hat wir halten wie finden sie
es denn nach der count gesperrt wurde
ja ich bin da noch etwas unschlüssig
grenze
grundsätzlich ist natürlich das
grundrecht auf freie meinungsäusserung
wichtig und darf man in ausnahmefällen
eingeschränkt werden andererseits muss
man sich eben ja auch vor augen führen
das ist gerade unter den unterstützern
ja immer wieder zu gewalt aufrufen kamen
deswegen ihr freund hatte ja vorhin
gesagt es gebe keine verschwörung was
die den sturm auf capitol angeht ich
persönlich sehe dass zumindest für
möglich dass es tatsächlich eine
verschwörung gab denn die anzeichen
waren ganz klar da in den sozialen
medien gab es aufrufe zu gewalt ist dies
occupied capital also besetzt das
kapitol
es kursierten baupläne der tunnel dies
unter dem kapitol gibt das fbi in
norfolk virginia hatte sogar vor dem
sturm aufs kapital tage vorher einen
bericht angefertigt und ausdrücklich
wörtlich vor einem krieg gewarnt und
dennoch waren die sicherheitsbehörden
offenbar auf beiden augen blind blind
also für mich ist das schwer da noch an
zufall zu glauben es werden ja
inzwischen sogar auch mehrere zehen
insgesamt mitglieder dieser capitol
polizei untersucht einige sind vom
dienst suspendiert worden
also das sind noch sehr viele ungeklärte
fragen und in dem zusammenhang kann man
eben auch sehen welche düstere und
koordinative rolle da die sozialen
medien gespielt haben
ihr freund wie finden sie es wie wichtig
war twitter für donald trump und was
bedeutet es dass das konto jetzt
gesperrt ist vollkommen korrekt hat er
die medien bei passt er konnte direkt
und ungefiltert mit seinen followern
sprechen
das ist schon für ihn ein handicap aber
andererseits natürlich frage ich mich
wie lange kann twitter das aufrecht
erhalten diese sperre und bis dahin wird
er natürlich diese rolle dass das ewig
ausgegrenzten des wasserkopf washington
der establishments des pflegen so lange
bis er wieder seinen twitter-account
bekommt also ich glaube das ist nur ein
scheinbarer erfolg dass der wirt nicht
lange anhalten also für ihn ist das eine
große einschränkung aber wie gesagt er
braucht jetzt erst mal nicht er ist kein
präsident mehr
er kann nur noch von außen sprechen also
ich glaube bin ein bisschen beim anteil
dass der politische betrieb irgendwann
seine seine fahrt aufnimmt und man
sollte sich nicht mit dem patch
immendingen und dingen der vergangenheit
beschäftigen sondern es muss amerika
jetzt wieder nach vorne gebracht
aber es gab auch konten von kuehn glaube
70.000 konten von weiteren wurden auch
gesperrt also das ist ja doch ja eine
möglichkeit dazu gewalt aufzurufen
dennoch ist dennoch dass anscheinend
einige personengruppen davon wussten
dass gewalt aufgerufen wird und dass
dann die polizei dort nicht
eingeschritten ist dass man sogar den
die zurückgehalten hat die
verantwortlichen person
und sind allesamt mittlerweile nicht
suspendiert teilweise haben aus dem
dienst entlassen worden
dh ich glaube da mehr an unfähigkeiten
untätigkeit der behörden
es scheint allerdings auch fehler in der
befehlskette der national guard gegeben
zu haben und zur verzögerung gekommen
sein
aber ich glaube nicht so recht daran
dass wir das mit absicht gemacht hat und
dann praktisch die republikaner ihren
präsidenten dort in seine gewalt
eskalation kommen zu lassen um ihn dann
danach für die sagt amerikaner zu
blackmail also ihn dort dafür
anzuprangern
also glaube der bogen erscheint mir
zurzeit zu weit gespannt okay wer kann
was bedeutet dass wenn wir diesen
machtwechsel jetzt haben wenn man sagt
wenn wir versuchen nach vorne zu schauen
in der außenpolitik hat sich viel
geändert in amerika ist das sozusagen
wirkt das noch nach ist die sind die usa
jetzt zu sagen das ende ist sind die am
ende als in ihrer position als weltmacht
also gleich zwei gedanken ich glaube ein
wirklich wirklich bedrückendes
bedrückende wirkung des letzten
mittwochs ist dass die usa liefen fast
versucht zu sagen endgültig ihre
funktion als modell des westens verloren
haben das ist mag reversibel erscheinen
dazu man merkt dass uhr zurückdrehen
können aber tatsächlich da ist doch viel
kaputtgegangen usa als modell und
natürlich kann man argumentieren das ist
bereits die jahre zuvor kaputtgegangen
in der sache demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit land der freiheit
einwanderungsland dass alle willkommen
heißt also all das was wir in einer
manchmal etwas naiven aber darum finde
ich gar nicht hinaus tradierten
perspektive mit den usa verbindet gerade
in der bundesrepublik was viele leute
auch trotz aller kritik im detail an den
usa fasziniert da sind doch erhebliche
schramm in den netzen er angekommen und
sondern die manifestieren sich in
besonderer weise an diesem mittwoch an
diesem sturm des capitol und es ist ja
kein zufall dass die reaktion aus peking
dass die reaktion aus moskau sofort die
war die man prognostizieren konnte dass
man sich die hände gerieben hat und
gesagt hat hier guck doch mal das sieht
doch ihr kritisiert ihr kritisiert
oder ihr unterstützt den sturm auf das
parlament in hongkong aber kritisiert
den strom auch das parlament in
washington das ist doch doppelmoral also
sagen dass die usa damit ihre eigene
führungsrolle unterminiert haben auch
gleich zweiter gedanke was uns jetzt
bevorsteht und der globalen ist ein land
oder eine präsidentschaft die sie erst
mal ganz stark innenpolitisch
orientieren wird
ich gehöre eine präsidentschaft erleben
die außenpolitisch nachvollziehbaren
gründen sich der welt nicht zu wenden
wird oder nicht mehr als unbedingt nötig
sondern tatsächlich erstmal angesichts
der themen die sie auch angesprochen
haben überwindung der coup folgen reform
des amerikanischen gesundheitssystems
anpassung der volkswirtschaft an die
klimapolitik notwendigkeiten reform des
bildungssystems und und und und und und
er soll sein wird unsere prettin sind
ganz woanders das wird nicht nur nach
innen
das wird nicht am erker first heißen
aber es wird in der politischen
prioritäten prioritätensetzung häufig
sehr ähnlich aussehen können sie es auch
so sehen und was also wie oder was
würden sie sich wünschen so zu sagen hat
jemand der eben von außen nicht darauf
amerika schaut die messlatte ist relativ
niedrig bleiben sagen wir so in volle
sätze sprechen keine faschist sein aber
ich hoffe er schafft das weil ich denke
weil hier freuen die für das auch
interessante wo probleme sind natürlich
interessierten kapitalismus wer möchte
nach amerika fahren im moment so ob wir
machen keine tritte disney lernt das ist
nicht mehr das gelernt es ist nicht mehr
attraktiv touristisch gesprochen oder
klar es gibt die beste universitäten und
so weiter aber die leute wehren möchte
im moment wirklich in ägypten gibt es
nette landschaft und sagen wir auch
nette leute aber an ich weiß nicht ich
kann auch ein weg um an ein guter kaffee
hier bekommen ende nicht nur in
deutschland es dieser land der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten die mir
einmal sind da also wie schaut man jetzt
auf amerika also ein biss war ja
wirklich auch immer so dieses
das gefühl im der hort der demokratie
und das ist das land wo ich das gefühl
sind dann wie ein freund das man kennt
aus die uni und wie gesagt ich bin 60
den main hat die die show die am
klassentreffen und man denkt was ist mit
1 freuen was mit dir passiert
ich hoffe dass die festivals sagt wie
können wir helfen weil wir brauchen user
das dann tut herr burgert wie würden sie
es einschätzen also wenn man jetzt wenn
beiden erstmal wirklich in die innen
nach innen schaut eben und nicht
unbedingt nach außen aber es wird sich
doch sicherlich schon einiges ändern in
der in dem miteinander im globalen
miteinander
ja das glaube ich auch der ton wird sich
ändern das wird wieder alles sehr
freundschaftlich und diplomatisch und
verbindlich im ton aber man darf sich
nichts vormachen in der substanz wird
auch joe biden zum beispiel von
deutschland mehr engagement fördern zb
bei der nato die einhaltung des zwei
prozent ziels also zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für verteidigung
auszugeben
das hat ja auch obama schon getan eben
nicht so lautstark und schrill wie trump
aber das sind ja keine neuen forderungen
im grunde die trump geäußert hat joe
biden wird von deutschland auch mehr
eine klare position gegenüber china
verlangen zum beispiel also da gibt es
durchaus auch konfliktpotenzial
aber sie haben völlig recht der ton wird
ein anderer sein und das wird
wahrscheinlich erst mal zu einer
gewissen erleichterung und auch zu einer
professionalität einer neuen in den
internationalen beziehungen führen denn
da lief ja einiges sehr chaotisch ab in
den vergangenen vier jahren es waren ja
teilweise ganze abteilungen im
außenministerium hier in den usa im
state department überhaupt nicht besetzt
man hat da ganz bewusst auch ein vakuum
entstehen lassen um sozusagen diese wie
steve barron ist einmal genannt hat
diese zerstörung des
verwaltungsapparates voranzutreiben und
insofern wird er jetzt erstmal ein stück
weit wieder normalität einkehrt
herr freund will amerika eigentlich noch
gerne die welt macht sein
ja ich denke schon aber mein bild auf
einer augenhöhe sein das heißt gleiche
regeln für alle
wir haben uns in deutschland ja daran
gewöhnt dass wir niedrigere
verteidigungsausgaben haben wir wurden
noch dazu angehalten für neutralität bis
1989 90 und wir haben natürlich die
höheren zölle und die höheren
importzölle und amerika hat eben die
niedrigeren importzölle und das ein
schöner zustand und ich bin auch für
freihandel aber dann bitte mit allen
seinen konsequenzen in deutschland ist
erwachsener geworden und muss mehr
verantwortung übernehmen er bekannt als
angesprochen dass zwei prozent
verteidigen will muss langsam
eingehalten werden
und natürlich wird auch bei
handelsfragen wie der differenzen geben
und da wird man auch sagen müssen wie
geht es weiter und dann natürlich will
amerika auch eine führende rolle spielen
aber sie möchten nicht nur für eine
rolle bei den damen beim zahlen spielen
es kann ja nicht sein dass bei über
dutzend bündnispartner in der nato
amerika bald 70 prozent des nato etats
stellt also das sind alles disco portion
die angesprochen werden müssen und
amerika sagt ich mache gerne ich mache
gerne die welt rolle in für die führende
weltmacht aber dann bitte mit meinen
bündnispartnern mit gleichen regeln und
pflichten für alle ist das spielt das
eine rolle wir haben jetzt ja schon
mehrmals über die 74 millionen wählern
wählerinnen und wähler gespannt ist das
was was irgendwo wichtig ist wie amerika
in der welt auftritt oder ist es
wirklich mehr dieses schauen nach innen
wie amerika sich als land präsentiert
und mit allen innenpolitischen fragen
also außenpolitik hat im amerikanischen
wahlkampf nie die entscheidende rolle
gespielt aber ich glaube jetzt ist der
blick nach china
doch stärker geworden ich glaube das ist
eine ausnahme oder eine besonderheit
dass dieser blick
china das dass dieser diese letzte sage
ich mal imperiale macht die ja auch im
südchinesischen meer beispielsweise dort
ihren einfluss ausüben will dass man
dort dem einhalt gebieten will dass
mittlerweile auch kein wahlkampf mehr
bestritten werden kann wir haben es ja
gesehen auch an joe biden den demokraten
die diesen blick für nach wenn man
diesen blick vernachlässigt hätte hätte
man möglicherweise eine knappe wahl
verloren also ich glaube ganz und diesen
außenpolitischen blick die das nicht
okay schauen wir in den letzten minuten
noch mal eben kurz auf die nächste woche
die vereidigung der dolmetscher nicht
teilnehmen möchte er keinem was erwarten
sie und was wäre wichtig für diesen tag
wie das ablaufen muss also ich hab schon
angedeutet ihr wart ein klares signal
der versöhnung der ausführung den
signale einheit wie es eigentlich
traditionsgemäß ist republikanische die
demokratische präsidentin immer diese
signale ausgesandt der wahlkampf war
hitzig der kampa kontrovers wir haben
uns einander die wunden geschlagen aber
jetzt ist die zeit neue styling jetzt
ist die zeit des heilens der
zusammenkunft und die frage ist ob wie
lange das trägt ob das umgesetzt werden
kann weil das ist natürlich in seinem
zwanzigsten januar schön gesagt die in
kleine frage ist doch dann wenn das
erste konkrete gesetzesvorhaben in den
amerikanischen kongress eingebracht wird
wie sich dann die mehrheiten gestalten
welche politik dann gerade die
opposition ihre publica verfolgen und ob
die beiden tatsächlich ein
programmatisches angebot machen kann was
für teile der 74 millionen attraktiv
sein könnte herr burkhard jetzt hab ich
auch schon den husten von ihnen bekommen
was denken sie worauf bereiten sie sich
vor
in der nächsten woche und was bedeutet
das dass trump da nicht dabei ist ja das
ist natürlich ein schlechtes symbol
sozusagen für diese versöhnung die ja
immer wieder angemahnt wird
trump ist der erste präsident seit 1869
seit andrew jackson der nicht an der
vereidigung seines vorgängers teilnimmt
und das sendet natürlich auch ein
gewisses signal zu sein 74 millionen
wählern dass er damit ja im grunde zum
zumindest symbolisch die legitimität
seines nachfolgers weiterhin nicht
anerkennt es gibt hier jetzt
spekulationen darüber ob seine tochter
ivanka vielleicht an der in operation
teilnimmt
das hat angeblich zu großen unmut bei
ihrem vater geführt
vizepräsident wird natürlich dabei sein
und ich glaube am allerwichtigsten jetzt
hier aus washingtoner sicht ist eben
dass es dann nicht zu neuen
ausschreitungen das ist nicht wieder zu
toten kommt dass die bilder die in die
welt gesendet werden friedlich sind und
das gezeigt wird das eben amerika dieser
demokratische tradition reibungslos über
die bühne bekommt was die rede von joe
biden angeht wird sich vermutlich wieder
auch in dieser metaphorik der heilung
bewegen sein wichtigstes
wahlkampfversprechen war ja die seele
amerikas zu heilen aber das klingt fast
ein bisschen naiv angesichts dessen was
man jetzt hier in den vergangenen wochen
aber eben auch in den vergangenen vier
jahren gesehen hat was die spaltung des
landes angeht also mir kommt es vor wie
eine mission impossible eine fast
unerfüllbare mission der sich da
vorgenommen hat okay kurz sie nachher
freund wie wichtig oder wenn sie es gut
ist rampen nicht dabei sein wird
also ist schade aber ich will trotzdem
den satz in dem gerade noch sagen ein
halbes dutzend us präsidenten waren
nicht bei der vereinigung dabei gewesen
der vergangenheit also das ist jetzt
nicht ganz was seltenes ist wäre ein
relativer basis machen würde
wäre ja aber nichtsdestotrotz halten sie
denn von ich dabei nicht also wo man
festhalten
also ganz so selten ist es nicht dass
sie über zehn prozent der präsidenten an
bord
ok freitag zum abschluss noch die frage
an die entertainerin ein ja werden sie
trump vermissen weil die förderung
kabarettistin und natürlich wirklich
jemand mit dem man sich gut bescheid
gibt es oft echte tiere denn die
wunderbare steven group er der beste
stadt ihr ist in ihrem ärger wir haben
comedy gehabt bevor donald trump ende
würden comedy haben nach dort rompuy dtm
er ist ein gefahr zu unserer nation und
zu die welt und ich finde es ist eine
schande dass er nicht da ist
ich finde das eine schande was los was
los war letzte woche auch lieber
kritische partei was los ist und ich
finde ich finde es gut wenn man an ihr
kommt sie möchte versöhnen bereits mania
da sein aber mein messlatte ist ein fakt
ist aber kommen lebendig durch nächster
woche okay das hoffen wir natürlich dass
es keine große gewalt geblieben in der
letzten woche gesehen dass es friedlich
ist unwahrscheinlich dann oder
vielleicht auch ein zeichen für die
heilung so wie joe biden ist immer sagt
das war die phoenix runde aber bleiben
sie einfach bei phoenix sender werden
sie natürlich weiter informiert in
phoenix der tag auch über alle
entwicklungen in washington und nächste
woche am 20 januar sind natürlich auch
für sie da und morgen gibt es eine
phoenix runde unter reden wir über den
cdu vorsitz bis dann tschüss